do you guys have a favorite bit from
jackass forever
that was my next question but of all
time your favorite bit of all time
my favorite bit of all time with me in
it is the wee man i bungee thing in
florida over the water yeah over the
water there's
did you ride that one no bandits oh
they're right bam you drew it on the
napkin that's right yeah yeah infects it
in yeah
so funny that's your favorite what about
one that you're not in
um
well i guess i'm in that too what am i
saying i was going to say dark room i
have the new ones oh my god so so funny
yeah were you really shaking like that
oh it was here's the deal so in there it
is terrifying i mean it's as terrifying
as it could be but then you start
thinking you know you're like wait a
minute they're not gonna let that snake
in here only because we could hurt the
snake they're not gonna take a risk of
us hurting a damn snake no way we don't
do that you know so then it's like well
wait a minute no snake what are they
gonna do and then it got just worse it
was worse it was like where's the snake
i want the snake you know yeah because
you're a gym that you know pj's in there
somewhere you know and so when they
knocked over the uh the snake did you
think the snake was really on the ground
somewhere no because it was uh everybody
else legit did
zach definitely thought there was a
rattlesnake going on and he definitely
thought he got bit
i thought i said boy chris sure seems
awful eager to take a cookie off a
rattlesnake's head with that or like
that part was just a given they're like
yeah chris is going to grow up with the
and say what are
you right he was like not even worried
about it he was like i'll just do that
so just sit here and watch i can see
chris being not too worried about that
but i fell for it i'm hooked on a sinker
i know for sure
damn
yeah when that door shut it was like oh
no
well it's funny because on the on the
movie
like you see you guys jumped when the
door shut because it seems so loud but
the audio wasn't that loud
so i was it was it just a [ __ ] loud
steel door that just slammed shut and
you guys were like oh no and it was deep
in the basement of this old college you
know way down he just kept going
downstairs and downstairs and downstairs
i think your gnarliest bit for me is uh
the field goal
oh right to the face yeah that was
[ __ ] heavy dude yeah that was a big
one was that one take
two takes okay did he get you the first
time it blew by my ear
and it's the only time knoxville ever
came up and put his hand on me he goes
it's okay
that's the only time he's ever done that
that football whizzed by my ears so fast
it's like oh [ __ ] and i said man you i
said dude you can't miss again he goes i
will not miss
and he didn't it was uppercut though
on the set of jackass 3d there was like
like famously like a no drinking rule
like we're gonna like respect stevo's
sobriety
and uh
like
you
your breaking of that rule was perfectly
appropriate every time
you know like
like like so and what president would
you like to see president was just like
hey man look i'm about to take a
football to the face i'm gonna need to
have a couple tricks you know
and like super respectful i was never
mad at once you know i only got in
trouble once on the uh walk the plank
right you got in trouble for that yeah i
got trouble for drinking on that one
yeah yeah that one was funny because
like it just didn't knock you off right
you're just stuck up there still
and then how was that cannon to the to
the stomach in the opening sequence
that wasn't as as bad as the one in the
oh you mean on forever yeah yeah that
was pretty rough because then you had a
bruise on another bit later no cannon
yeah yeah they only showed the bruise
right they didn't even show yeah i know
it's they showed jeff getting shot with
a damn gun and didn't show me oh well
right oh but you do you do get shot with
the cannon in the intro and the opening
scene yeah
and then later you see that big forever
both in both movies
right yeah okay and uh pirate in three
and then uh and forever i'm green punny
says dick
oh oh yeah right right right right
you'll be like shut up shut up okay go
oh
yeah
we're sitting there at one of those
writing meetings and they start talking
about that knoxville wrote that idea and
it's like yeah we need somebody with
balls that really hang down and every
face and everything turns on me and it's
like oh no you have because my balls
hang
ridiculously far down yeah no i really
they drip good
yeah so you've definitely had some cold
water a couple times and if they droop
down right
um in the toilets i mean
um you're just going to know if you
haven't hit the water okay
every now and then yeah it depends on if
it's low flow or not depends on the
height
i think i've hit water it is it's a
shock but it sounds shocked it sounds
like maybe your balls actually hang a
little lower than mine but if you watch
the footage on that look the first time
they hit them and then the second time
they didn't want to go down there
no way i was glad though that they kept
in like they did it once and tremaine
being like yeah you got to do it again
i like that kind of [ __ ] yeah that that
bit was less about the balls and more
about germaine being the evil guy who
always makes you do another team yeah
that sure wasn't a surprise that they
want to do another right right right
that's that that's part for the course
it was one of those though where i got
shot with a volleyball on a bungee cord
to the face to call the kissing booth
yeah man it hurt i mean it's it's
major smack the face and then jeff goes
come here and look and stevo's hand is
in front of the camera right there
because we got to do it again i'm so
sorry
i didn't even know
i don't know
what bit was that is it the kissing
booth
i think it was a 3.5 or something
it was a uh it was certainly a uh
phantom camera bit yeah
do you ever have a bit you backed out of
oh tons of bits really
anyone you regret one i uh regret no uh
hell no uh
the one where they were there was
mentos and soda pop or and diet coke
yeah where they were thrown around in
that room oh yeah yeah yeah i wanted
there's something about that that just
got me i figured i was gonna slip on
that stuff it looks slippery and like a
knee breaker and i just i told jeff i
didn't want to do it i was i was scared
to do that bit for some reason
you're talking about it when they all
just went in the room and just started
throwing them on the ground yeah
you just didn't want to do that
it ended up not even that gnarly of a
bit it wasn't that nice dude everybody
was afraid of that one yeah i just
excited for the only thing to do with
that bit
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]